sure that the living some is given by
and then they pull this rabbit out of a
hat trick thank you ok so before we jump
in and interview of what this series is
where is this series on my diagram
because this is the first place that
people make a mistake for instance a lot
of people just jump in and they say oh
well look there's a series there and I
ever series here so if you add I guess
the next one will be six side to the
four and then the one life that we 69
with five and you'll get a series it'll
be a GP right looks pretty good right
except for the fact that it's from home
what have I done wrong why isn't this
you serious d yeah very good de is not
one of these terms right this is a
really big common error that people man
so have a look at the actual go back to
the diagram right go back to your
diagram I've put BD and greens so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to put the
next one in green as well the next one
is EF that's this guy here you see so
that's the six sine cubed that we just
ended with yes and the next one after
that will be this guy and then this
guide and so on ok so very good since
you've noticed right my third term is GH
right which I actually don't know yet I
actually do need to go ahead and
demonstrate that I can find out what G H
is that part of where all those marks
coming now because I think you get the
process right I'm going to I'm not gonna
write that step but because what you're
asked to do is show show show show show
show and all I've got right now is one
two terms in the series right you
definitely need the third you need to
show like that GH is going to be six
sign to the five okay and the working is
going to be identical to this you just
got to go one step
and then another step after that to get
to the big power so now we're ready to
go what is this series what is this is
part two what is BD + e F plus G H
what's equal to well I'm just going to
put these terms together and I'm going
to see what emergent ok so I've got six
same here that's the first one there six
sine cubed and as you will show when you
complete this properly other than 600
okay now really nice if you they even
tell you there is a limiting some you
don't need to prove that this is the
case though in a minute just an
extension I won't go through how to do
that just in case they did ask them what
their for am I going to do with this if
I know that there's a limiting something
like they tell me isn't living some so
what will my next line bear it's good a
vision this is equal to a washrag rocks
on the song as I pao1 take away our do
you remember where this comes from you
noticed it's because if you put in this
which is the action will hold some of
the GP but if you have a ratio that's
making it gets more more more than what
happens as n approaches infinity this
guy just kind of disappears which is why
you just get n times 1 so that's where
AR 1 minus R comes from what I am I in
this case
so there's a on the numerator and I've
got one takeaway yeah good oh so you see
this and by the way just remember how I
said to you a common error was like
forming this series incorrectly like in
fact it was such a common error net back
in the other board of sightings to go up
with the website the markers notes which
is what happens in see Mike do I look
what's the common era is there here and
can still get something that makes sense
if I pick the right it wouldn't be one
minus sine square if I picked all three
terms what would this denominator the
play we r 1 minus side side leader right
you can still work with that you just
will never arrive here because you can't
cause it's the series okay so just watch
for that what do I do this this
denominator is just cos squared right
you see how it's a series of sequence
question but it's trying to ball in
together like what's a very simple trig
identity right so there's cos squared
and then we're pretty much there yeah
that's six times sign on cars times one
on because there is tan pair in sec okay
are you happy with that okay now I kind
of alluded to this before it's not part
of a question right now but I think like
this part 2 could easily have been a
part 3 and part 2 could have been sure
that there is a limiting some sure that
it exists that's a fairly common
question how would you go about doing
that if they did ask you to show that
there isn't a new song ok so here it
comes back to this argument here right I
will have a limiting song if R is going
to Tim out of the end is going to tend
towards your right so if you recall the
condition this is the condition I'm a
star remember that now hopefully it's
true but how I sure that it is true I do
this yes
one okay now pause for a second right
this is what I'm trying to prove so this
must be my last line how do i first life
right so I've got to be careful with
what I actually know what I stay there
yet done so I say a sine theta is found
advisor and it's minus 1 21 right and
that sign if sine theta was one right he
thanked 6 times whatever is would be 96
mm-hmm okay so if the next leg has to be
smaller okay for a second so just see if
you're following where rails going I see
where he's going it's probably not the
most direct way but it will work okay
this I think we all agree is the range
of sine theta yeah like we know what the
graph looks like okay so that's the
lowest thinking go and that's the
highest a figure however we kind of done
what this domain like this is not that's
right we don't let this range this is
not the right thing work this is the
range I work right I don't I need to
exclude the boundaries out okay now
what's the way the radars going to
exclude the boundary um just suppose
signed in or equal to 1 just just
suppose okay go with that mean here what
would this side be this side would be 6
times 1 which seeks in the next one
would also presumably be six and then
six and six and you would not have this
diagram okay so sine theta cannot
possibly be equal to 1 for that reason
yes it's okay um yes now this is true i
think that works fine i do find a little
bit awkward i think it's a simple way to
go about it
okay so yeah oh can you square it ah yes
but that doesn't solve the problem
because if our or equal to one that
asked rebels also be equal to 1 it's a
problem to disappear because they give
everything okay so theater is not just
any angle right I think the most plain
things to look at here is that theta
exists in a right angle try in fact
again for the extension to stints when
we will give Pollux perform that normal
right so if you've got an angle that's
less than 90 you can take advantage of
that it's in a triangle with a right
angle so it has to be a cute so i would
say instead of this because rather than
introduce a range and then it's
problematic range to try and fix it i
would say this i would say theta is less
than most refined it is less than 19
right as its inner i think i could stay
as it is in a right angle triangle right
that's the reason why this sine theta
now what's the range right this is this
is what sine theta looks like so what's
the range you thought between bottom
night it's just 0 to 1 exclusive right
so here I really should say that because
it's either triangle right therefore I
have sinus I have that degree that
and excluded my boundaries away because
I can't possibly have an angle of sight
zero or an anglicized 90 degrees not in
this triangular okay so from there I can
say okay well zero is still less than
science where assess the one yeah but
look at that that's all right that's it
0 is less the part 1 therefore well
that's that's that's that's more than we
need for this edition actually as long
as I'm not you want even name okay so i
would say therefore what was it called
de never named did it BD + e f plus g h
plus dot dot that has a living son
because I show this and sometimes like I
mentioned before showing you how to
living some is each immediate step
before you look at what the limit some
happens to be that you don't necessarily
like maybe 10 and Wanda's offices in
this case because of theta and what its
values are and the ratio being sine
squared theta you can be even more
restricted than that like this is the
greatest range it can possibly be but in
fact I'd even I'm narrower than that so
cool that means it's approve this and
then some so I don't need to worry I
getting at exactly like if what I'm
trying to prove is I've got a number and
I wanted to be less than 100 right when
we get into inequality pearson induction
later on this will become important if
you take that number and you somehow
prove it with less than one I think you
have succeeded right like people people
get open air I didn't get 100 on the
right hand side like I didn't get the
exact thing but that's okay inequalities
are like that if you're further in like
this is and that's why okay
would you have to do that um so I'm
trying to think of the way that they
would phrase the question such that like
see how this question it sort of just
hands it to you but there is a limiting
song if they were to do that then the
previous part would be you have to show
that there is one before I can RT to
evaluate right so I would I probably
have said part 2 would be show that that
has a living son taught three pence show
that that's equal to sure that it is 666
secondary art area that's the way I
would take it if my question was
serenity new bills anyway
if a piece that ipod need to try
yeah that works fine too yeah that
amounts to exactly the same thing as
this that's exactly right so all that to
say but hypotenuse which a B is in this
triangle must be the longest side in the
triangle so therefore this must be
shorter which means that this becomes
the new hypotenuse in another triangle
which means the nexel must be shorter
and so on I needs a bit less of a direct
path because then you've got it you've
got to do an intermediate step um where
is the way um so in this question let's
have a look in this question well
because because this question never
asked this that's why they never refer
to an engl enjoy that you absolutely can
a better tell you to do one get out loud
um not that it would make a difference
to me Jesse that's what we believe
geometry should be easy
um you know what not really because you
guys will start on when we all as a
class start doing reading measure on
tomorrow work tomorrow you're going to
see that the the line between like
measuring it this way and measuring that
way is very blurry like the reason we
introduced it now is because so we can
do calculus but that's not the only
reason you do it it's like we're looking
comics on its have nothing to do with
calculus and we're still raleys right so
once you all burn radians um I there's
no reason not to ever always use it
unless I tell you to use degrees